hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren wir machen heute eine nicht
lachen Challenge mit dem hilft mir Video
Sahne und käsewahnsinn für wie geht
Zimmer die Cousinen Sahne Susi und Käse
Kati
[Musik]
Sahne Susi und Käse Kathi es geht schon
brutal los die Cousinen Sahne Susi und
Käse Kati brauchen dringend einen neuen
Mitbewohner okay doch die beiden haben
ganz spezielle Vorstellungen was ist
denn das für ein geiler snacktisch hier
der ist also Tomaten Mozzarella ein
bisschen Käsekuchen ein gutes sind ja
auch Sahne Käse und Käse
genau
unsere Mühe es bleibt ja wohl mehr für
uns über Nacht keiner wusste unsere Mühe
zu schätzen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ziemlich abstoßen
die hat den Muffin Haarreif
ich habe hilf mir wirklich vermisst
sorry für die Verspätung
[Musik]
ich liebe selfie-team darf ich bitte mal
eine Folge für euch schneiden das wäre
mein größter Traum
geschafft es ist immer noch zu haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hat er dir jetzt so erkannt mäßig dass
er wusste dass die käsekarte heißt
Susi hallo
der ist Fan oder oder
scheint ein Jackpot zu sein um Käse Kati
und Sahnesoße sind total begeistert
Sahnekuchen oder Käse oder Käse und
Sahne passt auch nicht so gut obwohl
doch beides aus Milch ne ich habe keine
Ahnung jetzt beides nicht
[Musik]
dieses Bild hier
beschreibt die Folge schon perfekt dir
vielleicht irgendwas was ich ausfüllen
muss oder ja das haben wir hier
auch sehen mit wem wir es zu tun haben
[Musik]
Sahne Susi
das geht aber ein bisschen zu Waldemar
Wald
versteht bitte dass ich mich hier nicht
über die Personen lustig mache sondern
einfach nur über das
Endprodukt die ist nichts persönlich
attackierend gemeint aber dass sie dann
immer noch im Schnitt so Sachen
untermalen mit diesem Feen Geräusch und
so das ist einfach Comedy die sie gar
nicht sein wollen also super
[Musik]
wie Grinch muss das da auf dem Dreh sein
mit denen
hast
drei Wörter lesen müsste man eigentlich
noch hinkriegen
werde ich sogar die Sahne von der Brust
lecken
[Musik]
heute bin diese hilf mir Abwechslung
wenn ich in Köln sondern in Berlin
habt ihr den Ärger mit Sahne Susi und
Käse Kati wie ich nein er wird mir
gehören er liebt es von mir um ganz zu
werden Mitte
das ist doch wirklich
schauspielerisch
einfach nur der Erdkern
ich musste sogar erst zweimal nach links
gucken um dich
ey das ist überhaupt nicht negativ
gemeint und er ist richtig beleidigend
sie kann die netteste Frau der Welt sein
aber wenn man in den schauspielrichtung
geht dann muss man doch zumindest den
Text können er hat ja seine Handynummer
aufgeschrieben und ich schreibe ihm
gleich ja wow mach komm mach mach ich
bin schon ganz aufgerichte
[Musik]
Käse iPhone Hülle
die ist voll schön dass es klappt hat
ein Zug morgen Mittag
Einzug morgen Mittag richtig schnell
beide Cousinen Wetten darum wer den Mann
bekommt aber ich würde zu bedenken geben
dass der Mann da auch noch ein Wörtchen
mit zu reden hat Quatsch
das dürfen nur Sahne Susi und käsekarte
entscheiden
für dich vorbereitet oh mein Gott sie
hat eine gelbe Hose an und ein Käse Herz
T-Shirt
ich
[Musik]
Kriege heute Nacht wieder Albträume von
dir das Robert beim Schleppen geholfen
hast die ab hier übernehme ich
es ist
es ist ich es ist die ganzen Leckereien
ganzer Käse
[Musik]
ich verstehe nur nicht ganz
am Tag davor woher die
Wohnungsbesichtigung hatte hat er sich
doch noch so leidenschaftlich gern die
Mario Tube den Käse und die Sahne
reingesteckt und jetzt 24 Stunden später
kann der Käse nicht mehr sehen oder wie
schmeckt dir denn
jetzt habe ich noch was ganz besonderes
für dich
eine extra Box
[Musik]
an der Stelle würde ich einfach nur noch
sagen
[Applaus]
einfach lachen